From PRI, Public Radio International--
来自PRI，国际公共广播电台——
From PRI, Public Radio--
来自PRI，公共广播——
From PRI--
来自PRI——
Public Radio International--
国际公共广播电台——
Public Radio--
公共广播——
Public--
公共——
Radio international.
国际广播电台。
--radio international.
——国际广播电台。
One more time.
再来一次。
From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life . I'm Ira Glass. Well, a few weeks ago, we invited you to send us your stories of life on the internet, to send unusual or amusing email exchanges, interesting things you've found in Usenet groups or on web pages. Hundreds of people responded. I recorded interviews with some of them and invited the ones who live here in Chicago to Chicago's Museum of Contemporary Art for a show. Today on our program, what happened when all the tapes and readings and people were gathered onstage in the museum's theater.
这里是芝加哥WBEZ电台，《美国生活》节目。我是艾拉·格拉斯。嗯，几周前，我们邀请大家寄来你们在互联网上的生活故事，寄来你们那些不同寻常或有趣的邮件往来，以及你们在Usenet新闻组或网页上发现的有趣东西。成百上千的人做出了回应。我记录了其中一些人的采访，并邀请居住在芝加哥的受访者来到芝加哥当代艺术博物馆参加一场演出。今天的节目，我们将带大家看看当所有的磁带、朗读稿和人们齐聚博物馆剧院的舞台上时，发生了什么。
So Mary is 19 years old, an English major at the University of Washington. And one day, she's cruising the net, visiting the home pages of complete strangers.
玛丽今年19岁，是华盛顿大学的英语专业学生。一天，她在网上冲浪，浏览着完全陌生人的主页。
And I came across this site that I thought was amazing. It was the most cutting-edge, thought-provoking site I'd ever seen. And so I was examining it, checking it out. And I realized that this guy was my age. And he worked at Microsoft. And that just blew me away, because I'm a student. I can barely afford coffee in the morning. And here, this guy worked at Microsoft.
我偶然发现了一个让我觉得非常惊艳的网站。那是我见过的最前卫、最发人深省的网站。所以我仔细研究了它，浏览了它。我发现这个家伙和我同龄。而且他在微软工作。这让我大吃一惊，因为我还是个学生，早上一杯咖啡都快喝不起了，而这家伙居然在微软工作。
I ended up emailing him, just to tell him how much I liked his site and how amazing I thought it was. And he wrote back. And that went on for about four or five days. We just kept writing back and forth, really personal stuff, too, not just computer geek stuff.
我最终给他发了邮件，只是想告诉他我有多喜欢他的网站，觉得它有多棒。他回信了。这种情况持续了大约四五天。我们一直在写信往来，谈的都是非常私人的话题，不仅仅是电脑极客那些事儿。
What is the brave new world of the internet? I would argue that one main difference between regular life and life on the net is that you can meet a stranger and get to know them intimately, much faster on the net than you can anywhere else. Well, for a week, Mary and this guy right each other several times a day, long, personal emails. Then they agreed to meet in person at a coffee shop on Valentine's Day.
互联网这个勇敢的新世界到底是什么？我认为普通生活与网络生活的一个主要区别在于，你可以在网络上比在任何地方都更快地结识一个陌生人并深入了解对方。好吧，那一周里，玛丽和这个家伙每天互通几封长篇私人的电子邮件。后来他们约定在情人节那天在一家咖啡馆见面。
I was nervous before we met, because I was worried that he wouldn't find me as interesting in real life. So we met for coffee. We ended up spending the next 12 hours together. There wasn't really a turning point until a few days later. We had continued to see each other. And one night, we ended up going out to his office at Microsoft. It was about midnight, and nobody was there. And we were hanging out. And one thing led to another, and all of a sudden, we were making out.
见面之前我很紧张，因为我担心他在现实生活中会觉得我没那么有趣。我们在咖啡馆见面。最终我们接下来的12个小时都是在一起度过的。直到几天后才有了真正的转折。我们继续见面。有一天晚上，我们去了他在微软的办公室。当时大约是午夜，那里一个人也没有。我们待在那儿。后来顺理成章，我们就亲热起来了。
And?
然后呢？
It was crazy.
太疯狂了。
And you were glad, though, because you were liking him.
但你很高兴，因为你对他有好感。
Oh, yeah. Yeah. It wasn't a bad thing. But it was awkward, because it was my first time. I had never really done that with anybody before.
哦，是的。是的。那不算坏事。但很尴尬，因为这是我的第一次。我以前从未和任何人那样做过。
It was your very first time actually having sex with somebody?
这是你第一次真正和别人发生性关系？
Right. Well, no, it was my first time kissing anybody.
对。呃，不，这是我第一次和任何人接吻。
Kissing anybody at all?
任何人都没有？
Yeah.
是的。
Because you hadn't had a high school boyfriend who you would do that with?
因为你上高中时没有交往过男朋友？
No, no. I was a real big loner in high school. I didn't get out much.
没有，没有。我高中时是个彻头彻尾的独行侠。我不怎么出门。
So it was your first time just making out with somebody, and it was at Microsoft.
所以这是你第一次和别人亲热，而且是在微软。
Yeah. And so it made it all the more surreal, I think. It was just weird for me to think that, here's this guy I met a little over a week ago by chance on the internet. And here we are at his office, doing this.
是的。所以我认为这让一切显得更加离奇。我觉得很奇怪，想想看，这是一个我一周多前在互联网上偶然认识的家伙。现在我们就在他的办公室里，做着这些事。
And then after that, I barely heard from him. He told me that he didn't want a relationship right now, that he wanted to wait. He kept using the term, he wanted to make his first million before he had a relationship with somebody.
在那之后，我几乎没再收到他的消息。他告诉我他现在不想建立恋爱关系，他想等等。他一直用这个说法，他说他在建立恋爱关系之前想先赚到第一个一百万。
His first million?
他的第一个一百万？
Yes.
是的。
For all the hype about the revolutionary changes the internet is going to bring us, what's striking about this particular story is how much of it could have happened without computers at all. All across America, teenage boys kiss young women on a date or two, then freak out and withdraw. All the computer adds is an air of mystery and intimacy and some exotic stage props for the drama. Otherwise, the lines and the moves are very, very old.
尽管人们大肆炒作互联网将给我们带来的革命性变化，但这个故事特别引人注目的一点是，其中有多少内容即使没有电脑也能发生。在全美各地，十几岁的男孩在约会一两次后吻了年轻女孩，然后就吓坏了并退缩。电脑所增加的只是神秘感、亲密氛围以及为这场戏码提供的一些异国情调的道具。除此之外，那些台词和举动是非常、非常古老的。
After the fact, after the night at his office down there at Microsoft, I noticed, boy, he really was feeding me some lines there.
事后，在微软办公室那一晚之后，我注意到，天哪，他当时真的在对我耍手段。
Really?
真的吗？
Yeah.
是的。
Like what else?
还说了些别的吗？
He actually was going to set me up with a copy of Office 97. He never did.
他其实打算送我一份《Office 97》的拷贝。但他从来没给过。
The cad. At what point in the whole interaction did he promise you the Office 97, the free software?
真是个花花公子。在整个互动过程中，他是在什么时候承诺给你《Office 97》这款免费软件的？
Actually, the first night we met.
其实，我们见面当晚。
Did you just think, he's feeding me a lot of soup?
你当时有没有想，他是在跟你吹牛？
No. I thought it was cool, because I'd heard some things about Office 97. I thought, wow, I'd like to have that.
没有。我觉得这很酷，因为我听说过一些关于《Office 97》的事。我心想，哇，我想要那个。
Now, I'm sure you can only look back on the incredible naivete. Some young man is prowling the streets of Seattle, walking through the U District, telling women--
现在，我肯定你只能回顾那段不可思议的幼稚时光。某个年轻人在西雅图街头徘徊，走过大学区，告诉女人们——
"Got your free software."
“给你免费软件。”
Well, the question we pose in this hour is, what is happening on the internet? And are there things happening on the net that never would have happened without it? Over the past few weeks, we've advertised in cities around the country, inviting radio listeners to send us samples of their own emails, samples of things they've found on the net that they thought were especially interesting or amusing. We have advertised here in Chicago, asking people to come here today, to the museum of contemporary art, with those samples. And over the next hour, we'll hear from people here and people around the country, an unscientific sampling of what's going on on the net. Stay with us.
嗯，我们在这一个小时里提出的问题是，互联网上到底在发生什么？互联网上发生的事情是否是如果没有它就绝对不会发生的？在过去几周里，我们在全国各地的城市做了广告，邀请听众把他们自己的电子邮件样本寄给我们，把他们认为特别有趣或好玩的网上发现发给我们。我们也在芝加哥做了宣传，请大家今天带着这些样本来到当代艺术博物馆。在接下来的一小时里，我们将倾听这里的人们和全国各地人们的分享，这是一次关于网上正在发生什么的非科学抽样。请继续收听。
My co-host for today's show is David Hauptschein. Welcome, David. David is a playwright and novelist. His played "Trance" won the Fringe First Award at the Edinburgh Theatre Festival and was produced for the Brighton Arts Festival. His play "The Persecution of Arnold Petch" premiered this year at Red Orchid Theater here in Chicago. And years ago, David started having these shows that he called "letter shows," where he invited people onstage to bring their mail to a theater and read it, just as kind of a big open mic. And we're adapting the format of those shows to the electronic media today. David, why don't you explain the rules of how one of these shows goes.
今天的联合主持人是大卫·豪普沙因。欢迎大卫。大卫是一位剧作家和小说家。他的作品《恍惚》在爱丁堡戏剧节上获得了“边缘先锋奖”，并被制作并在布莱顿艺术节上演出。他的剧作《迫害阿诺德·佩奇》今年在芝加哥的红兰剧院首演。多年前，大卫开始举办他所谓的“信件展”，邀请人们带着他们的信件来到剧院并当众朗读，就像一种大型的开放麦。今天，我们将这些演出的形式改编用于电子媒体。大卫，你为什么不解释一下这种演出的规则呢。
OK. This is a show with many, many rules. That's why we have two hosts up here. Ira does half of them, and I do the other half. The first rule is the time rule. These are egg timers. These are mechanical devices that do not exist in cyberspace. They are crude. They're holding at approximately four minutes. And that's what everybody will have when they're presenting.
好的。这是一个有很多很多规则的节目。这就是为什么我们这里有两位主持人。艾拉负责其中一半，我负责另一半。第一条规则是时间规则。这些是计时器。这些是在网络空间里不存在的机械装置。它们很粗糙。每个人大概有四分钟的时间。这就是大家在展示时所拥有的时间。
Let's give a sample ding, so people know what to expect.
我们先试着响一下铃，让大家知道会发生什么。
Oh, yeah. Sample ding. Well, these different dings. But we're going to start with this one here. This is your basic [DING]. So when you hear that, you must stop mid-syllable and just exit the stage, unless one of us starts talking to you or something. So we're going to begin with Joe Fosco. In preparation for this show, we spent many hours surfing the net together and finding files that we thought were interesting. And Joe's going to come up and read some. Wait a minute, Joe, let me get this timer going, here. I've got to put these other ones in different places.
哦，是的。试响一下。嗯，这些不同的铃声。但我们要从这个开始。这就是你们基本的[叮]声。所以当你听到那个声音时，你必须在说话的中途停止并立刻离开舞台，除非我们中有人开始和你交谈或做点什么。所以我们要从乔·福斯科开始。为了准备这个节目，我们花了很多时间一起上网冲浪，寻找我们认为有趣的文档。乔要上来读一些。等一下，乔，让我先把这个计时器启动。我得把这些其他的铃放在不同的地方。
This one I'm going to read now is a website of this guy who's building an aluminum ball, ball of aluminum foil. And he went into quite a bit of detail about this ball. He says, "I don't remember exactly how the ball began, but it is a sphere, composed entirely of aluminum foil of various varieties. It is mostly candy wrappers with a few bits of foil and other food items mixed in. So far, the best finish coat is York Peppermint Pattie wrappers. Other foil is fine, but a coat of Peppermint Pattie wrappers is necessary to keep it on. Gum wrappers also tend to have their quality. But they are far too difficult to peel, considering the minimal bulk they have. Gum wrappers do make a good finish coat on top of Peppermint Pattie wrappers for show. Some items, such as Hershey's Miniatures, which look like they might be good candidates for foil, aren't. The ball is more impressive in person than this page can hope to depict."
我现在要读的这个网页是一个家伙的，他正在制作一个铝球，一个铝箔球。他对自己制作这个球的过程做了相当详细的描述。他说：“我不记得这个球究竟是怎么开始的，但它是一个完全由各种铝箔组成的球体。它主要是糖果包装纸，混合了一些铝箔和其他食物残渣。到目前为止，最好的表层涂料是约克薄荷饼包装纸。其他铝箔也可以，但必须涂上一层薄荷饼包装纸才能固定住。口香糖包装纸也倾向于有它们的品质。但考虑到它们体积很小，剥皮实在太难了。口香糖包装纸确实能在薄荷饼包装纸上面做出一层很好的装饰表层。有些物品，比如好时迷你巧克力，看起来像是很好的铝箔候选者，但其实不然。这个球本人看起来比这个网页能呈现出来的更令人印象深刻。”
There's a picture of the ball.
有那个球的照片。
Oh, there is, if you can see it. And then, he has this diary of its growth. It starts back in January. And he says, "We've gotten an electric postage scale in the office. It reads one more digit of precision, so we now have a weight of 3.9 ounces. I have done the math to compute the density of the ball. Curiously, it is much lower than that of solid aluminum. I have a hard time believing that the ball is less than half aluminum by mass, so I invite you to let me know if there are any errors in my computations. I expected that the density would be less than that of solid aluminum because of a small amount of air between layers of the foil, the adhesive coatings, inks, and small quantities of chocolate, grease, and other leftovers from the food items that the wrappers were originally used to package. I wouldn't have been too surprised by 5 or even 10% difference. But I find the actual results obtained a little difficult to believe."
哦，如果你能看到的话，确实有。然后，他有这个成长的日记。它是从一月份开始的。他说：“办公室里有了一台电子邮票秤。它能读出多一位的精度，所以现在的重量是3.9盎司。我已经做了数学计算来测算这个球的密度。奇怪的是，它比实心铝的密度低得多。我很难相信这个球的质量中铝的含量不到一半，所以如果我的计算有任何错误，欢迎随时告诉我。我预计密度会低于实心铝，因为铝箔层之间有少量的空气、粘合剂涂层、油墨以及少量的巧克力、油脂和其他原始包装食物留下的残渣。如果是5%甚至10%的差异，我也不会太惊讶。但我发现得到的实际结果令人难以置信。”
I have a question for you, Joe. Do you believe that fellow would be making that ball if it wasn't for the internet?
我问你个问题，乔。你认为如果不是因为互联网，那个家伙会制造那个球吗？
I think so.
我觉得会的。
See, I think that one of the discussions we've been having the past couple of weeks is, is the internet unique in any way? And I think that it is in the sense that people now know they have potentially millions of--
你看，我认为我们过去几周一直在讨论的话题之一是，互联网在任何方面是独特的吗？我认为在某种意义上它是独特的，因为人们现在知道他们可能拥有数百万的——
Readers.
读者。
--readers. Whereas before, a guy would make a silver ball. He'd make a silver ball and put it in his desk, and no one would know about it.
——读者。而以前，一个人做了个银球，他把它放在桌子里，没有人会知道。
The other interesting thing is, on this, he has links to other sites that are making aluminum foil balls, and someone also who's making a rubber band ball.
另一个有趣的事情是，在这个网页上，他有指向其他制作铝箔球的网站的链接，还有一个人在制作橡皮筋球。
But I think, actually, the idea that he might get some notoriety out of his ball has spurred him on to further-- at least, maybe it would've been a mediocre ball. I think he's working it out to make the ultimate ball. All right. Thank you, Joe.
但我认为，事实上，他可能会从他的球中获得一些名声的想法确实激励了他……至少，也许那本来会是一个平庸的球。我认为他正在努力打造终极之球。好的。谢谢你，乔。
Our next reader, Stacy.
我们的下一位朗读者，斯泰西。
Oh, this is Stacy.
哦，这位是斯泰西。
Do I just start?
我可以开始了吗？
You can just start.
你可以直接开始。
Tell us anything you think we need to know, or just start right in.
告诉我们任何你认为我们需要知道的事情，或者直接开始。
I'm just going to set the timer for four minutes.
我先把计时器设为四分钟。
OK. A former friend of mine from high school is currently living with her husband and son in England. And every three weeks or so, she sends out what I call a broadcast email. And she sends it to what has now become 56 email addresses. I'm going to read one of the broadcast emails. But before I do, I think I should make two notes. One is that she refers to her husband as "Bobo" or "Bo." And she refers to her son as "Boo" because she named him after Boo Radley in To Kill a Mockingbird .
好的。我的一位高中好友目前和她的丈夫及儿子住在英国。大约每三周，她就会发送一份我称之为广播邮件的内容。她把它发给现在已经有56个电子邮件地址的人。我要读其中一封广播邮件。但在我读之前，我想我应该做两点说明。一是她称她的丈夫为“博博”或“博”。她称她的儿子为“布”，因为她是以《杀死一只知更鸟》里的布·拉德利的名字命名的。
That's a strange choice.
那是一个奇怪的选择。
Granted, that is his nickname. So she also rates her adventures with "paws," like bear paws. And for example, once, after visiting the Stratford on Avon, she said, "Three paws for Shakespeareville." So here's the first one that I ever received.
当然，那是他的昵称。所以她还给她的探险经历打分，用“爪子”，就像熊掌那样。例如，有一次，在参观完埃文河畔斯特拉特福之后，她说：“莎士比亚小镇，三只爪子。”所以这是我收到的第一封。
"Hi. Baby Boo had his first day in London this weekend. We went to the British Museum, a quick stop to Harod's, and really quick stops to Big Ben and Westminster Abbey to take pictures. We bought a six-foot diameter beach towel that I lay out for Boo to play on. I told him that it's his boundary, and if he crawls off it, he'll get electrocuted from the wires. You know, like those dog training things. Well, he does a good job of keeping me on my feet now. Before, I had to watch him every second. Now, I have to watch him every millisecond."
“嗨。小布这个周末在伦敦度过了第一天。我们去了大英博物馆，快速逛了哈罗德百货，还快速去了大本钟和威斯敏斯特教堂拍照。我们买了一条直径六英尺的沙滩巾，我铺在地上让布在上面玩。我告诉他那是他的边界，如果他爬出去，就会被电线电死。你知道，就像那种训狗的东西。嗯，他现在确实很擅长让我忙得团团转。以前，我每秒都要看着他。现在，我必须每毫秒都要看着他。”
You know what this is like? It's like one of those Christmas letters. How often does she--
你知道这像什么吗？这就像那种圣诞信件。她多久——
Exactly. But this comes-- I think I've received these over the last year. And these come fairly regularly, like once a month.
完全正确。但这来自于——我想我在过去一年里收到了这些邮件。它们相当规律地发送，就像一个月一次。
And for you, as somebody who knows her, when you read these, do you feel a sense of, yes, I must know, or is it, oh, no?
对你来说，作为一个了解她的人，当你读这些时，你感到一种“是的，我必须知道”，还是“噢，不”？
Well, actually, what's really interesting is that she and I have grown apart. And I didn't really quite know how to end the relationship. But these emails have actually given me some closure, because--
嗯，事实上，真正有趣的是她和我已经疏远了。我真的不知道该如何结束这段关系。但这些邮件实际上给了我一种了结，因为——
Because now, you never have to say anything.
因为现在，你永远不必说什么。
I don't say anything. It used to-- [DING]
我什么都不用说。过去常常—— [叮]
Keep going. Finish your thought.
继续。说完你的想法。
Oh, ok. And I never have to say anything. I never respond to them. But she continues to send them to me, and I have a lot of fun reading them. And before, I used to feel really guilty. Like I wouldn't respond to her letters or I wouldn't be a good friend. But now, I feel like, OK, well, we're just so different.
哦，好的。我永远不必说什么。我从来不回复它们。但她继续发给我，我读的时候觉得很有意思。而以前，我会感到非常内疚。好像我不回复她的信或者不是个好朋友。但现在，我觉得，好吧，我们只是太不一样了。
I don't want to be a good friend.
我不想做一个好朋友。
Right, right.
对，对。
Once a month, it comes to you in a vision.
一个月一次，它以幻象的形式来到你面前。
Right. And then I just read it. And actually-- I'm really horrible, and I can't believe I'm going to admit this-- but I actually send it out to two of my other friends, who also-- [LAUGHTER] I forward it to two other friends, who are sitting out there. And they read it and comment back to me. I can't believe I'm saying this.
对。然后我就读它。事实上——我真的很糟糕，我不敢相信我要承认这一点——我实际上把它转发给了我的另外两个朋友，她们也—— [笑声] 我转发给了坐在那里的另外两个朋友。她们读了并回复评论。我不敢相信我在说这些。
Well, she doesn't listen to the radio, does she?
嗯，她不听电台，对吧？
My friends and I sat and thought about it. And we thought, well, I don't think she listens to NPR.
我和我的朋友坐在一起想过这个问题。我们觉得，嗯，我不认为她听NPR。
Thank you.
谢谢。
Well, for our next one, I thought we'd do one that people contacted us when we advertised around the country for things going on on the net. And somebody notified us about this one web page. We were searching for people who were having experiences on the net they would never have otherwise. And this particular page was made by woman named Jenny Ringley, a senior at Dickinson College in Pennsylvania. Like a lot of people, she created her own little home page on the World Wide Web.
嗯，对于下一个内容，我想我们选一个人们在我们全国各地做宣传寻找网上动态时联系我们的案例。有人通知了我们这个网页。我们一直在寻找那些在网上获得了否则绝不可能获得的经历的人。这个特定的页面是由一位名叫珍妮·林格利的女子制作的，她是宾夕法尼亚州迪金森学院的大四学生。像很多人一样，她在万维网上创建了自己的小主页。
There's the regular part of my page, I guess you would say, with information about me, the music I like, things like that, like everybody has on their page. The one item that has become extremely popular, though, is the JenniCam. And it's just a camera that sits in my room and takes a picture every three minutes and uploads it. So every three minutes, you can find out what fascinating thing I'm doing in my room.
我想说，我的页面有常规部分，有关于我的信息、我喜欢的音乐等等，就像大家页面上都有的那样。但变得非常流行的一项是“珍妮摄像头”。它只是一个放在我房间里的摄像头，每三分钟拍一张照片并上传。所以每三分钟，你就能知道我在房间里在做什么有趣的事情。
The JenniCam is on seven days a week, 24 hours a day. And the number of people who want to see what fascinating thing is going on in a college girl's dorm room each day?
“珍妮摄像头”一周七天、一天24小时开着。而那些每天想看看大学女生宿舍里发生了什么有趣事情的人数呢？
People, I'm not sure. But as far as number of hits go, we get over 500,000 hits a day.
具体人数我不太确定。但就点击量而言，我们每天有超过50万次的点击。
A half million hits, every single day. And what do people see?
每天50万次点击。而人们看到了什么？
Nothing, really. I write email, I sleep, I have friends over. You can watch my hedgehog when I'm not in the room. Things like that. Pretty much just regular college life, as far as I know.
没什么，真的。我写邮件，我睡觉，我有朋友过来。我不在房间时你们可以看到我的刺猬。类似这些事情。据我所知，基本上就是普通的大学生活。
Our associate producer tuned in to your page, just to kind of see what was going on. And for about a half an hour, she witnessed you on the phone. Every three minutes, there'd be another picture of you in a different position, on the telephone.
我们的副制片人调到了你的页面，只是想看看在发生什么。在大约半小时的时间里，她见证了你在打电话。每隔三分钟，就会有另一张你在不同姿势下打电话的照片。
I talk on the phone a lot.
我经常打电话。
In a way, it's hard to think of anything more banal than seeing a college student's dorm room.
从某种程度上讲，很难想到还有什么比看大学生的宿舍更平庸的事情了。
I would have to agree. I would absolutely agree. I don't do anything that's that interesting. I don't have company very often. I don't do anything more interesting, really, than talk on the phone, watch TV, and sleep.
我完全同意。我绝对同意。我没做什么特别有趣的事。我很少有客人。我做的真的没有比打电话、看电视和睡觉更有趣的事情了。
Let me ask you to talk about the nudity.
让我请你谈谈裸露的事。
Well, whenever I'm nude in my room, I'm nude on the JenniCam.
嗯，只要我在房间里没穿衣服，我在“珍妮摄像头”前就没穿衣服。
But, you know, when I think about how often somebody is nude in the course of a day, it's really not very long.
但是，你知道，当我想起一个人在一天里没穿衣服的频率有多高时，其实时间并不长。
Well, maybe I'm not an average person. But I figure when I'm alone, who really cares? I sleep naked, and I get changed. And when I get out of the shower, I'm all wet. There's no hurry to put on clothes.
嗯，也许我不是个普通人。但我认为当我独自一人时，谁在乎呢？我裸睡，我换衣服。洗完澡出来时，我浑身湿透。没必要急着穿衣服。
Explain what the thrill is about being naked in front of a computer camera.
解释一下在电脑摄像头前裸露的快感是什么。
Actually, with the camera there, I don't think about it much. So whenever I'm normally naked in my room, that's when I would be on the camera. It really doesn't affect me in much of a big way, I would say.
其实，有了那个摄像头，我并不怎么想它。所以每当我平时在房间里没穿衣服时，那就是我会出现在摄像头前的时候。我觉得这对我影响不大。
But wait. You're saying you're being naked in front of potentially a half million people, and it means nothing to you?
等等。你是说你在潜在的50万人面前裸露，而这对你来说什么意义都没有？
I think the camera would be a lot less interesting if I paid that much attention to it. It would be more of a staged show. And you can go see a staged show anywhere. I think the whole appeal of the camera is that it is whatever is normally going on in my room. And with it having been up for a year and a half now, I'm pretty accustomed to it being there. It doesn't affect me much, I would say.
我想如果我太在意摄像头的话，它会变得无趣得多。那会更像是一场精心编排的表演。而你可以在任何地方看到表演。我认为摄像头的所有吸引力在于，它是任何在我房间里正常发生的事情。既然它已经开了一年半了，我已经习惯了它的存在。我想它对我影响不大。
Have there been any moments over the last two years where you were sort of sorry that the camera was in the dorm room?
在过去两年里有没有过那种你有点后悔摄像头在宿舍房间里的时刻？
Actually, it goes sort of the opposite way. Whenever I go home for breaks, for spring break or something like that, I'm always sad to be away from the camera. It's really a different feeling. Whenever I'm in the room and the camera is broken for some reason, my room feels totally different. It's like I'm completely alone. I usually prefer the camera be there. And I'm sad when it's off as opposed to wishing it weren't there.
其实，正好相反。每当我放假回家，比如春假什么的，我总是很难过离开那个摄像头。那真的是一种不同的感觉。每当我还在房间里而摄像头因为某种原因坏了，我的房间感觉完全不同。就像我彻底孤身一人。我通常更喜欢摄像头在那里。当它关掉时，我感到难过，而不是希望它不在那里。
Because you don't feel alone when it's on.
因为当它开着时，你不觉得孤单。
Right. Even though there's nobody actually there with me, even though I'm still alone, even if there's nobody watching the camera from the other end, it's just comforting to know that there is somebody metaphorically out there.
对。即使实际上没有人在那里陪我，即使我仍然是一个人，即使另一端没有人观看摄像头，知道在某种隐喻层面上有人在那里，这还是很安慰人的。
In your view, why are so many people checking out the site each day?
在你看来，为什么每天有那么多人查看这个网站？
A lot of the people, it's totally hoping to find me getting out of the shower, getting dressed for bed, things like that. It's hoping to find the nudity. But I get lots of email from people who say that it's just nice, when they're alone in their office, to know that there's somebody else out there, somebody else that is doing nothing more interesting than what they're doing at the same time. It's like having a little virtual friend.
很多人，他们完全是希望发现我从浴室出来、穿上睡衣、诸如此类的事情。他们是希望看到裸露。但我收到很多人的邮件，他们说，当他们独自在办公室时，知道外面还有人，还有人在做着和他们同样无聊的事情，这感觉真好。这就像拥有一个小小的虚拟朋友。
Now, at some point in the two years, you've probably had somebody over in the dorm room to mess around.
在过去的两年里，某个时间你可能带过某人到宿舍里来鬼混。
Sure.
当然。
And?
然后呢？
At that point, it goes on the other person's comfortability. I have no problem doing that. And that's the whole point of the camera, is that it's whatever I'm doing. When I went into this, I understood that in order to make it really work, it would have to be no matter what I was doing. But I can't really enforce that on people who are visiting me. So if the other person is uncomfortable, then the camera is turned off or it points to a different part of the room.
在那一点上，取决于对方的舒适度。我做这事没问题。这就是摄像头的所有意义所在，它记录下我正在做的任何事情。当我开始做这个的时候，我就明白，要让它真正发挥作用，无论我在做什么都必须记录下来。但我不能强迫来访的人那样做。所以如果对方感到不舒服，那么摄像头就会被关掉，或者指向房间的另一部分。
And generally, has the other person been uncomfortable?
通常情况下，对方会感到不舒服吗？
Yes. Yes.
是的。是的。
Was there ever a time that you actually had somebody over where you actually kept the camera on the two of you?
有没有哪一次你带人回来的时候，真的让摄像头一直对着你们俩？
Yes, in fact. And the funny thing is that it never actually was broadcast, because the number of people suddenly reloading on the server ended up crashing the computer that posted the JenniCam at the time.
确实有过。有趣的是，它从未真正播出，因为服务器上突然增加的重载请求最终导致当时发布“珍妮摄像头”的电脑崩溃了。
Wow.
哇。
So even though we were there and the camera was on, the server was crashed by the number of people wanting to see.
所以即使我们在那里而且摄像头开着，服务器也被那些想看的人潮给挤瘫痪了。
What's your impression of who these people are?
你对这些人是谁有什么印象吗？
Oh, I don't know. Mostly men. It's almost exclusively men. I get about 700 emails a day. And of that number, maybe 10 are from women.
哦，我不知道。大多是男人。几乎全是男性。我每天收到大约700封邮件。其中，大概10封来自女性。
You get 700 emails a day?
你每天收到700封邮件？
Right.
对。
What are people saying to you?
人们都在对你说什么？
Well, a lot of those are entries to a contest on my web page called "Name That Curve," where, once a week, I put up a new picture of some closeup shot of a part of my body, and people guess what it is. So I would say 300 or so of that number are "Name That Curve" entries. The rest of them are people saying either, "I saw your web page. I like your page," or "Can I call you?" Or "Can you send me private, special pictures?" It really, really ranges.
嗯，其中很多是参加我网页上一个叫“猜猜那曲线”比赛的参赛作品，每周我都会放一张我身体某部分特写的照片，人们猜那是什么。所以我认为其中300封左右是“猜猜那曲线”的参赛作品。剩下的是人们说，“我看到了你的网页。我喜欢你的页面，”或者“我可以给你打电话吗？”或者“你能发给我私人、特别的照片吗？”真的是五花八门。
Jenny says she spends five to six hours a day answering email. And when I talked to her, on the one hand, there seemed to be something completely innocent in what she was doing, putting herself out there and not really caring who sees. And if you press her about her own exhibitionism, she'll tell you over and over, "Oh, no, no, no. It's not about exhibitionism. It's an experiment in letting people view a person's entire life without editing." The one thing that she's gotten on the internet that she could never have gotten so easily any other way is she's famous within a small circle. It's a small, particular kind of thing.
珍妮说她每天花五到六个小时回复邮件。当我与她交谈时，一方面，她所做的事情似乎非常无辜，把自己展现出来而不真正在乎谁在看。如果你追问她的表演欲，她会一遍又一遍地告诉你，“噢，不，不，不。这不是关于表演欲。这是一个实验，让人们可以不经编辑地观看一个人的整个人生。”她在互联网上获得的、以任何其他方式都无法如此轻易获得的一件事是，她在一个小圈子里出名了。这是一种小型的、特殊的东西。
I do get a fair number at this point of requests for autographed pictures and people wanting to buy my hair and my clothing, things like that.
此时此刻，我确实收到了不少要求签名照片的请求，还有人想买我的头发和衣服，诸如此类的事情。
What?
什么？
It's pretty scary. Well, one time, I was caught on camera actually trimming my bangs, because if you're going to do that, it's cheaper. And all of a sudden, I got 40 emails from people saying, "Are you going to do anything with that hair? Can I buy it from you?"
这挺可怕的。嗯，有一次，我在摄像头前修剪刘海时被抓拍到了，因为如果你要那样做，自己剪更便宜。突然间，我收到了40封邮件，人们说，“你要处理那些头发吗？我可以从你那里买吗？”
And what did you make of that?
对此你怎么看？
Well, I don't know. It's kind of scary. I do meet people from time to time. Somebody'll say, "I'm passing through the area. Do you think I could meet you?"
嗯，我不知道。这有点可怕。我确实不时地见到这些人。有人会说，“我经过这一地区。你觉得我能见你吗？”
And you say?
然后你回答？
I actually have a pretty good knack for getting a good feeling about people right off the bat. So sometimes I say no. Sometimes I say yes. I've had dinner with, oh, probably a dozen people from the JenniCam.
我确实有一种能立刻对人产生良好感觉的诀窍。所以有时候我说不。有时候我说好。我可能和大概十几个人共进过晚餐，都是通过“珍妮摄像头”认识的。
And has that been nice?
那感觉还不错吗？
I had one person who had a hard time taking no for an answer, even after I made it abundantly clear I wasn't interested.
我有过一个人，即使在我明确表示我不感兴趣后，他也很难接受拒绝。
Really, that's kind of creepy.
真的，那挺让人毛骨悚然的。
It is, kind of. I've had a fair number of improper passes at the end of the evening. But it stays at a pass.
确实，有点。在晚上结束时，我遇到过不少不当的求欢。但也就止步于求欢。
If there were a cable channel that would just have a camera on in your room, with no sound, 24 hours a day, do you think you'd get a half million viewers?
如果有一个有线电视频道可以在你的房间里装个摄像头，没有声音，一天24小时播放，你觉得你会拥有50万观众吗？
I don't think so. I don't think I would, because if you have the TV, you have other things you can watch. I think it would still be popular. But I think at that point, it would be a lot less interesting, because people can do this from their offices. At work, if they have internet usage that's not monitored from work, you can just put it on and leave it on in the background while you're doing whatever else on your computer.
我不这么认为。我不觉得会有，因为如果你有电视，你还有其他东西可以看。我想它仍然会受欢迎。但我觉得在那一点上，它会无趣得多，因为人们可以在办公室里做这个。在工作中，如果他们有工作场所不受监控的互联网使用权限，你可以在电脑上做其他事情时，把它开着并在后台运行。
Jenny Ringley has just graduated from college. She's moved to another city, where she's gotten a job designing web pages for a big national magazine.
珍妮·林格利刚刚从大学毕业。她搬到了另一个城市，在那里找到了一份为一家大型全国性杂志设计网页的工作。
Coming up, other tales from the net. That's in a minute when our program continues.
接下来，更多来自网络的故事。一分钟后我们的节目继续。
It's This American Life . I'm Ira Glass. Most weeks in our program, we choose a theme, bring you a variety of different kinds of stories on that theme. But this week, we are trying something different. We're broadcasting from the Museum of Contemporary Art, here in Chicago, where we're taking what geologists might call a core sample of things happening on the internet, a very unscientific sample. How are people using the net? What is happening on the net that is not happening anywhere else or has not happened anywhere else?
这里是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。我们节目大多数周都会选择一个主题，为您带来围绕该主题的各种不同类型的故事。但这一周，我们正在尝试一些不同的东西。我们正在芝加哥的当代艺术博物馆进行广播，在这里，我们正在采集地质学家所说的关于互联网上发生事情的“核心样本”，一个非常非科学的样本。人们是如何使用网络的？互联网上发生了什么而在其他任何地方没有发生，或者以前没有发生过的？
Over the last few weeks, we have advertised, asking people to come here today with things they have found on the net, including their own email exchanges. People from around the country are joining by telephone. My co-host today is playwright David Hauptschein, who's conducted these kinds of events in the past onstage here in Chicago. Welcome back, David.
过去几周里，我们做了广告，邀请人们今天带着他们在网上发现的东西来到这里，包括他们自己的邮件往来。全国各地的人们通过电话加入。我今天的主持搭档是剧作家大卫·豪普沙因，他过去曾在芝加哥的舞台上举办过此类活动。欢迎回来，大卫。
Thank you.
谢谢。
Well, now, this example of people's lives changed by the internet. Eileen and Fred Kiefer live outside Columbus, Ohio. They are septuagenarians with seven kids and 13 grandkids.
嗯，现在，这个关于人们的生活被互联网改变的例子。艾琳和弗雷德·基弗住在俄亥俄州哥伦布市郊外。他们是七个孩子和13个孙辈的祖父母。
OK, well, when we first got our email going on our computer, I sent a message to our son in Milwaukee, whose address was K-I-E-F-F.
好的，嗯，当我们刚开始在电脑上使用电子邮件时，我给我们在密尔沃基的儿子发了一条消息，他的地址是K-I-E-F-F。
K-I-E-F-F.
K-I-E-F-F。
Yeah. But it was my first time to use it, and I left one of the F's off.
是的。但那是我第一次使用它，我少打了一个F。
Her email was a chatty email about everything going on in the family, signed, "Love, Mom."
她的邮件是一封关于家里发生的所有事情的闲聊邮件，署名是“爱你的妈妈”。
So I got back a letter from someone whose address was K-I-E-F. And he said, "I enjoyed this letter, but I don't think you meant it for me." So then, I wrote back and said thanks, and explained how I'd make the mistake. And he wrote back. And we've been writing now for, it'll be two years this month.
所以我收到了一封回信，对方地址是K-I-E-F。他说：“我很喜欢这封信，但我认为你不是发给我的。”所以后来，我回信表示感谢，并解释了我犯的错误。他也回了信。我们现在已经写了两年了，本月就是两周年。
The man, the couple, actually, who got her email were Kiefer and Galen Mitchell in Portland, Oregon. He works at Tandy and does a radio show out there. And when he got Mrs. Kiefer's email in his account, the thing that actually got to him was that she signed it, "Love, Mom." His own mother had just died two months before. His father had been dead for years. Mrs. Kiefer said she never intended or wanted to have a long-term email friendship.
那个男人，实际上是那对夫妇，收到她邮件的是俄勒冈州波特兰市的基弗和盖伦·米切尔。他在坦迪公司工作，并在那里主持一档广播节目。当基弗夫人的邮件进入他的账户时，真正触动他的是她署名“爱你的妈妈”。他自己的母亲刚在两个月前去世。他的父亲也去世多年了。基弗夫人说她从未打算或想要一段长期的电子邮件友谊。
It seems like we had nothing in common going in-- the age difference, and they had no children. And they're Mormons, and we're Catholics. It seemed like there wasn't a whole lot that we had to talk about. But we never have any trouble.
起初我们似乎没有什么共同点——年龄差距，而且他们没有孩子。他们是摩门教徒，而我们是天主教徒。看起来我们似乎没有什么可以谈论的。但我们从来没有任何麻烦。
At first, we were writing every day. We were both so excited about this. And now, we're usually in touch at least once a week. And we visited. And he's in Oregon. We're in Ohio. Visited in Portland last year and spent a couple days with him and had a wonderful time. And they're, like, 30 years younger than we are. So we've become Mom and Dad. And we've adopted them. They call them our illegally adopted children. And in December, when I had a serious operation, he was on the phone every night just like the rest of our kids. So he's really become one of our kids.
起初，我们每天都在写信。我们俩都对此非常兴奋。现在，我们通常至少每周联系一次。而且我们互相访问过。他在俄勒冈。我们在俄亥俄。去年在波特兰互访，和他在一起待了几天，玩得很开心。他们比我们年轻30岁。所以我们成了爸爸妈妈。我们收养了他们。他们称他们为我们“非法收养的孩子”。去年十二月，当我做了一次大手术时，他每晚都在电话上，就像我们的其他孩子一样。所以他真的成了我们的孩子之一。
So what in the world was it in those first emails they sent two years ago? What could people possibly say to create a bond like that?
那么，两年前他们发送的第一批邮件里到底写了什么？人们怎么可能通过这些建立起那样的纽带？
Oh, I don't remember. I just remember indicating that I was 70. So I didn't want anybody to think we were going to have this big romance or anything. Because, you know, you read these stories about people doing weird things with people on the internet. We never had that problem. We have seven children. And all of them have email except one. And the ones out of town we hear from a couple times a week. One of our daughters we hear from almost daily.
哦，我不记得了。我只记得说明了我70岁了。所以我不想让任何人认为我们要搞什么大浪漫之类的。因为，你知道，你读过关于人们在互联网上与人做奇怪事情的故事。我们从来没有那种问题。我们有七个孩子。除了一个以外，他们都有电子邮件。外地的孩子们我们每周都会听到几次。我们的一个女儿我们几乎每天都会联系。
Now, did you have as much contact with them before email?
那么，在用邮件之前你们有这么多联系吗？
Oh, no. No, we would talk on the phone maybe once a month. And it was always, "How are you?" And you never really were part of their lives that way. Two of our children live in Boston. And while we were always close, we weren't communicating very often.
噢，没有。没有，我们可能一个月打一次电话。而且总是，“你好吗？”你从来没有真正以那种方式成为他们生活的一部分。我们的两个孩子住在波士顿。虽然我们一直很亲近，但我们没有经常沟通。
So email has really brought you all closer together.
所以电子邮件真的让你们所有人更亲近了。
Oh, it's wonderful. I keep trying to talk everybody I know into it if their children have access to a computer. It's changed our lives a lot. It's just changed our lives. I wouldn't think of not checking the computer first thing in the morning to see who's writing.
噢，这太棒了。如果孩子能接触到电脑，我一直在尝试劝说我认识的每个人都用它。它改变了我们的生活很多。它彻底改变了我们的生活。早上一睁眼我不检查电脑看看谁在写信是不可想象的。
Eileen Kiefer in Dublin, Ohio.
俄亥俄州都柏林的艾琳·基弗。
Another reader?
还有下一位朗读者吗？
You have one there?
你那里还有吗？
Sure, plenty.
当然，多的是。
OK, let's go with another reader.
好的，我们再请一位朗读者。
Our next reader participant, Steve Sedin.
下一位参与朗读者，史蒂夫·塞丁。
Steve Sedin.
史蒂夫·塞丁。
I came across a Usenet group called alt.amazonwomen.admirers. And this is a short dialogue between two guys.
我偶然发现了一个叫alt.amazonwomen.admirers的Usenet小组。这是两个男人之间的简短对话。
Guy one: "I was just talking with someone. And we started thinking about a couple of girls we know that used to give us piggyback rides. Here's an interesting thought. One girl was, like, 5'2", weighed 110 pounds. She wasn't a great athlete and didn't have a lot of muscle, and she was able to give me piggyback rides with ease, while I weigh close to 200 pounds. So with that thought in mind, I'm curious to know, assuming you believe that piggyback rides are the easiest way to lift a person, which they are, how much weight would you guess some fitness and body building women could lift piggyback? I mean, if they can lift 200-pound guys over their shoulders and press them overhead, just imagine how much they could lift piggyback. Any thoughts?"
甲男：“我刚才和人聊天。我们开始想我们认识的几个以前会背我们骑马的女孩。这是一个有趣的想法。一个女孩身高5英尺2英寸，体重110磅。她不是个伟大的运动员，也没有多少肌肉，但她可以轻松地背我，而我体重接近200磅。所以考虑到这一点，我很好奇，假设你认为背人是举起一个人的最简单方式，事实也确实如此，你猜一些健身和健美女性能背起多重的人？我的意思是，如果她们能把200磅的男人扛在肩上举过头顶，想象一下她们背着人能举起多少。有什么想法吗？”
So the response to that is, "Yeah, here's a thought. Where are the lift-a-200-pound-man-overhead-and-press-him women? Boy, would I ever like to see that. I mean, who cares about piggyback rides? A piggyback ride isn't a lift at all. The man just climbs on. And all the weight is supported by the bones of the legs, because the legs are already locked out. Not impressive, not sexy. But to see a woman militarily press a man, now, that's worth paying to see. My greatest thrill would be to see a tall, muscular woman pick up a tiny man under his armpits and dangle him in midair. Impossible, you say? Maybe. But consider this. In 1988, the women's weightlifting championships were dominated by young, teenage girls. I saw a 16-year-old Chinese girl snatch 165 pounds as though it were a feather. She cleaned and jerked 231 pounds without so much as making a face. She weighed 132 pounds. Try this, guys. Go to your garage and load up that old barbell with, say, 270 pounds. Try to dead-lift it. See how heavy it feels. Now, picture a cute, 17-year-old 99-pound pound Chinese girl take that same barbell and lift it all the way overhead in about five seconds." So the response to that is, "Yes, I agree. Now we're getting close to the real thing." Thank you.
回应是，“是的，有一个想法。那些能把200磅的男人举过头顶的女人在哪里？天哪，我多想看一眼。我是说，谁在乎背着骑马？背着骑马根本不是举重。男人只是爬上去。所有的重量都由腿骨支撑，因为腿已经是锁定的状态了。不令人印象深刻，也不性感。但看到一个女人用军事姿势举起一个男人，那才叫值得一看。我最大的快感是看到一个高大、肌肉发达的女人把一个娇小的男人从腋下拎起来，悬在半空中。不可能，你说？也许吧。但考虑一下。1988年，女子举重锦标赛被年轻的十几岁女孩所统治。我看到一个16岁的中国女孩像抓羽毛一样抓起165磅。她以抓举和挺举的方式举起了231磅，连眉头都没皱一下。她体重132磅。试试这个，伙计们。去你的车库，把那个旧杠铃装上大概270磅。尝试硬拉它。看看感觉有多重。现在，想象一个可爱的17岁、99磅重的中国女孩拿起同一个杠铃，并在五秒钟内把它完全举过头顶。”所以回应是，“是的，我同意。现在我们接近真实的情况了。”谢谢。
[APPLAUSE]
[掌声]
Our next reader, Dolores.
下一位朗读者，多洛雷斯。
Dolores.
多洛雷斯。
OK, this is a romance story. I met this guy last fall. And he worked most of the week in another part of the country. He would fly out on Sunday night and come back on Thursday night. So our romance was conducted through the net. And because he was away so much, we talked or emailed back and forth every day.
好的，这是一个浪漫故事。去年秋天我认识了这个家伙。他一周的大部分时间都在国内的其他地区工作。他周日晚上飞走，周四晚上回来。所以我们的恋情是在网上进行的。而且因为他经常不在，我们每天都在网上聊天或互发邮件。
And I don't know if other people have had this experience, but if you start going out with someone and you're writing them over the net, it's very exciting. You come home, and you turn on the computer, and it's one of the first things that you think about. And it really adds this element that, I don't know, I've never had before.
我不知道其他人是否有过这种经历，但如果你开始和某人交往，而且是通过网络写信，这非常令人兴奋。你回家，打开电脑，这是你首先想到的事情之一。它确实增加了一种我以前从未有过的内容。
So anyway, we went out for about three or four months. And we fell in love. But eventually, we started to have problems. Our daily correspondence became more and more strained. And finally, I wrote him this email that I'm going to read to you.
总之，我们交往了大约三四个月。我们坠入爱河。但最终，我们开始出现问题。我们的日常通讯变得越来越紧张。最后，我给他写了这封邮件，我要读给你听。
"Dear Sam, I feel like I'm making you feel worse, and I can't bear that. I am so sorry. I think that you should have peace. And I pray for you. I pray for that for you every day. I think you should take some time and call me when you do feel more peace."
“亲爱的萨姆，我觉得我让你感觉更糟了，我无法忍受。真的很抱歉。我认为你应该得到平静。我为你祈祷。我每天都为你祈祷。我认为你应该花点时间，当你感到更平静时给我打电话。”
So this was very heartfelt. And I did think that he would write me back. And after about two and a half weeks, he hadn't written me. And this was a dramatic departure for us.
这非常真诚。我确实认为他会回信。在大约两周半后，他还没有写信。这对比我们来说是一个巨大的转变。
And so when we finally did talk, it was like Vietnam. There was about 36 hours of a intense meltdown. And I fired out five hysterical emails, which I won't read to you. And we broke up. And while we were breaking up, my computer crashed. And I lost all of my email. And so I lost all of this correspondence from him, which was 100 pages, easily. And I wrote him. And I told them about this. And he sent me two caches of folders, his mail and my mail.
所以当我们终于交谈时，就像越战一样。有大约36小时的激烈崩溃。我发出了五封歇斯底里的邮件，我就不读给你听了。我们分手了。在我们分手的时候，我的电脑崩溃了。我丢失了所有的邮件。所以我丢失了所有与他的通讯，轻松超过100页。我写信给他。我告诉了他这些事。他寄给了我两个文件夹缓存，他的邮件和我的邮件。
Well, at that time, I didn't want to read through all of this. It was a little too painful. I just wanted it. I wanted to have it. So when I prepared for this show tonight, I decided to go back and read through it. And I discovered something, which was that he did email me back. I just never got it. And part of the hell-- I was in hell for those two or three weeks before we talked.
嗯，当时，我不想读完所有这些。这太痛苦了。我只是想要它。我想拥有它。所以当我为今晚的演出做准备时，我决定回去读一遍。我发现了一些事情，那就是他确实给我回信了。我只是从来没收到。而且这部分地狱——在我们交谈前的两三周里，我一直处于地狱中。
So this is what he emailed me that I discovered. It said, "Dolores, you are so good a person. I'm very proud to know you and have you in my life. I will take some time and get grounded, and then call you. Thanks for all your love and understanding." Well, I was flabbergasted. It took me several days to even wrap my mind around the fact that he had sent this. And it completely altered my experience of that time and of him. And I still can't quite assimilate it, really.
所以这是我发现的，他给我发的邮件。上面写着：“多洛雷斯，你是一个非常好的人。我为你感到自豪，能在我的生命中有你。我会花点时间让自己沉淀下来，然后再给你打电话。感谢你所有的爱和理解。”嗯，我目瞪口呆。我花了几天时间才理清这样一个事实：他已经发了这个。它完全改变了我对那段时间以及对他的体验。我现在仍然无法完全消化它，真的。
Do you think it's possible that he faked it when he sent you the batch of emails back?
你认为有没有可能当他把那批邮件发回给你时，他在造假？
Now, this is the question that every man I tell this story to asks me. It didn't occur to me. And he would have had to have gone through quite a bit of trouble to do it, because it is encoded with all of the information. I don't know. What do you think?
现在，这就是每一个我讲这个故事的男人问我的问题。这事儿我没想过。而且他必须费很大劲才能做到，因为它被编码了所有的信息。我不知道。你觉得呢？
I yield to your expertise here.
我在这里向你的专业知识让步。
Yeah. Yeah. OK,
是的。是的。好的。
Thank you.
谢谢。
Our next reader, Sarah, is somebody who has a story for us.
下一位朗读者，莎拉，是一位有故事要告诉我们的人。
This involves a guy who picked out my photo in what we call the "MeetBook" for incoming freshmen. It has every freshman and a little bio data. And he liked me. But none of our friends knew each other, so he couldn't meet me. And what he ended up doing was obsessing about my photo and deciding, well, I can't just obsess about her photo. I'd like to know more about her as a person.
这涉及一个家伙，他在我们所谓的“新生手册”中挑出了我的照片。上面有每个新生和一点生物数据。他喜欢我。但我们的朋友互不认识，所以他没法见我。他最后做的是沉迷于我的照片，并决定，好吧，我不能只沉迷于她的照片。我想更多地了解她这个人。
So he sent out this broadcast message to everybody in the dorm I lived in that was on the net at the time, asking what I was like. So all these strangers responded. And they just made stuff up. But it was very positive, because what happened was, he ended up writing me a letter on paper, using quotes about all the things that people had said about me, that I was cheerful and intelligent and had a good disposition. He decided I was a rare commodity. I should call him. And I was kind of cornered into calling him by my friends. But this is a story that went nowhere, because he was truly not someone I wanted to end up going out with.
于是他发了一封广播消息给当时网上所有住在我宿舍里的人，询问我是一个什么样的人。所以所有这些陌生人都做出了回应。他们只是编造了一些东西。但它非常积极，因为发生的情况是，他最终用纸写了一封信给我，引用了所有人对我的评价，说我很开朗、聪明、性格好。他断定我是稀有品种。我应该给他打电话。我在朋友的怂恿下不得不给他打电话。但这故事没下文，因为他真的不是我想交往的那种人。
Do you think that the way that he decided to approach you was a tip-off that that might have been?
你认为他决定接近你的方式是一个暗示，暗示可能那会是这样？
Yeah, I have to admit that-- the first thing he said when I called him up-- because he was really nervous, and I really didn't care-- he said, "OK, we can get together. But not Friday night, because Friday night's the ping-pong tournament."
是的，我不得不承认——我给他打电话时他说的第一句话——因为他真的很紧张，而我真的不在乎——他说，“好吧，我们可以见面。但周五晚上不行，因为周五晚上有乒乓球锦标赛。”
Yeah, there's a sign right there.
是的，那立刻就是一个信号。
Well, thank you for that, the rigmarole.
好吧，谢谢你的那个繁文缛节。
Our next presenter, our next reader, Noel.
下一位演讲者，下一位朗读者，诺埃尔。
My name is Noel, and I'm diastematic. Anybody here know what that means? It means that I have a gap between my front two teeth. For those of you unfamiliar with this whole website gap-tooth thing, I built a website for gap-tooth people. So, yeah, idiotic. You want it, you've got it. But I'm in good company. 10% of America, including David Letterman, Lauren Hutton, Noam Chomsky, Supreme Court Justice Sandra Day O'Connor, Itzhak Perlman, Chaucer's Wife of Bath, Vince Lombardi, blah, blah, blah, all with two cleavage. I must admit, for better or for worse, yes, I'm the one who built this website. But the emphasis is humor.
我叫诺埃尔，我是牙缝患者。这里有人知道那是什么意思吗？这意味着我的门牙之间有缝隙。对于那些不熟悉这种整个网站牙缝事物的人，我为牙缝人建立了一个网站。所以，是的，够白痴的。你想要它，你就有它。但我处于很好的行列中。10%的美国人，包括大卫·莱特曼、劳伦·赫顿、诺姆·乔姆斯基、最高法院大法官桑德拉·戴·奥康纳、伊扎克·帕尔曼、乔叟的巴斯妇人、文斯·隆巴迪等等，等等，都有牙缝。我必须承认，无论好坏，是的，我是那个建立这个网站的人。但重点是幽默。
In early November last year--
去年十一月初——
Wait, humor verses what? Like attacks at people without gaps in their teeth? What would be other thing that you would do-- you would proselytize, try bring people over, encourage people to create gaps in their teeth?
等等，幽默对比什么？比如攻击那些牙齿没缝的人？你还会做其他什么事情——你会传教，尝试把人拉过来，鼓励人们在牙齿上制造缝隙？
Absolutely.
绝对。
Are you working with any orthodontists?
你和牙医合作吗？
This will hit on a lot of those themes. In the early November last year, I was watching a Bears-Packers game. And during the pregame ceremonies, the USPS, the post office, unveiled art for a new stamp, due this summer, featuring the late great Vince Lombardi, who was one of the greatest gappers ever to live. He was on a stamp, riding high atop the team in the throes of victory, smiling huge. But something was missing, Coach Lombardi's trademark gap-toothed grin. He had near-perfect pearly whites, and the gap was gone.
这将触及很多那些主题。去年十一月初，我正在看一场熊队对包装工队的比赛。赛前仪式上，USPS，邮局，揭幕了一张新邮票的艺术图，定于今年夏天发行，主角是已故的伟大的文斯·隆巴迪，他是史上最伟大的牙缝人之一。他在邮票上，骑在高处，正处在胜利的狂欢中，大笑。但缺了点东西，教练隆巴迪标志性的牙缝笑容。他有一口近乎完美的珍珠白，缝隙不见了。
The next day, as a joke, I added a page to the gap-tooth website, protesting the post office's depiction of Lombardi as a cosmetically-altered hero. Who would Don King be if he were bald? Or Gorbachev without the Kool-Aid stain? Or Jimmy Durante without that nose?
第二天，作为一个玩笑，我在牙缝网站上加了一个页面，抗议邮局对隆巴迪作为一名整过容英雄的描绘。如果唐·金秃头了会是谁？或者没有那个红色污渍的戈尔巴乔夫？或者没有那个鼻子的吉米·杜兰特？
So knowing that this was one small effort to have a little fun while making a point, knowing that this was the Web, the oddball media that gets no real merit for its content, I expected little to no attention. But then came Yahoo, which featured it as a weekly pick. The Washington Post had me on the phone and ran a half-page story with my before and after pics. Chicago's Channel 7 came to my apartment and ran a story on its 6 o'clock news just for the Super Bowl.
所以知道这只是一个小小的尝试，在表达观点时找点乐趣，知道这是网络，一个内容毫无价值的怪异媒体，我预料它几乎不会引起注意。但后来雅虎出现了，把它作为每周精选。华盛顿邮报给我打了电话，并刊登了一篇带我前后对比照的半页故事。芝加哥第7频道来到我的公寓，在6点新闻中专门为超级碗播了一条新闻。
Getting out of hand? Yeah, timeout. If you're thinking this pathetic web-based protest should never have received any attention, I'm in agreement with you. What was ironic about this story is that they painted me as a freak-- imagine that-- a superfan, ready to strap myself with bombs and blow up my teeth and Washington, D.C., if they didn't change the art. And it was all pretty much lighthearted.
失控了吗？是的，暂停。如果你认为这种可悲的、基于网络的抗议根本不应该得到任何注意，我和你意见一致。关于这个故事讽刺的是，他们把我描绘成一个怪胎——想象一下——一个超级粉丝，准备好把自己捆上炸弹，炸掉我的牙齿和华盛顿特区，如果他们不改变那件艺术品的话。而这一切基本上都非常轻快。
So Bob, the artist of the postage stamp, latched back to the AP. And I thought, this is just fun. I mean, I'm just running a website for gap-toothed people. You can't take me that seriously. So I called up Bob, and we talked about the stamp. We discussed angles and art representation. He was a really nice guy. I was thinking about dropping the protest already when he told me his three-year-old daughter was gap-toothed.
所以鲍勃，邮票的艺术家，回击了美联社。我想，这只是好玩。我是说，我只是在为牙缝人经营一个网站。你不能太当真。所以我给鲍勃打了电话，我们谈了邮票。我们讨论了角度和艺术表现。他是个非常好的人。当他告诉我他三岁的女儿有牙缝时，我已经在考虑放弃抗议了。
And that was it. Protest over. But what still gets me today is that the Web has the power to make insignificant things seem real, that email can really serve as a powerful form of protest, which it did in this case, and that people, including myself, really do have too much time on their hands.
就是这样。抗议结束。但今天仍然让我感到触动的是，网络有能力让无关紧要的事情显得真实，电子邮件确实可以作为一种强大的抗议形式，就像它在这个案例中那样，以及人们，包括我自己，确实手上有太多的时间。
Well, as we looked for those stories from the net for this show, especially stories of things happened on that net might not happen anywhere else, we found Earl Jackson. He's an associate professor of Comparative Literature at the University of California at Santa Cruz. And he spends a lot of time on the net. He writes about the net, has seven websites himself. And he tells the story, which begins on America Online.
好吧，当我们为这个节目寻找那些来自网络的故事时，特别是那些发生在网络上可能在其他任何地方都不会发生的故事，我们找到了厄尔·杰克逊。他是加州大学圣克鲁斯分校比较文学系的副教授。他花了很多时间在网上。他写关于网络的东西，自己拥有七个网站。他讲了一个故事，故事始于美国在线。
I was on AOL and other services in San Francisco a lot. And there are these chat rooms where gay men can meet and talk. And in San Francisco, it's fairly wild. There's a 24-hour bulletin board that I was observing for this study was doing, where you could almost be guaranteed that, if you lived in San Francisco and you had a modem, you could have sex any time of the day or night. This was a very goal-directed bulletin board.
我在旧金山经常使用AOL和其他服务。这里有一些聊天室，男同性恋者可以在那里见面和交谈。在旧金山，这相当狂野。有一个24小时的公告栏，我正在观察这个研究，几乎可以保证，如果你住在旧金山且有一台调制解调器，你可以一天或晚上的任何时候进行性行为。这是一个非常目标明确的公告栏。
Right, people would meet, go have sex.
对，人们会见面，去进行性行为。
Right. And you would know exactly what they wanted to do. And you'd probably have nude pictures of them before that. What I also thought was really interesting-- and this was more true of AOL-- that there was a new metaphysics of sexuality, because people would talk about cybersex or real sex. And it occurred to me, after I listened to enough, by real sex, they meant phone sex.
对。而且你会清楚地知道他们想做什么。在那之前你可能会有他们的裸照。我还觉得真正有趣的是——这在美国在线上更真实——有一种性行为的新形而上学，因为人们会谈论网络性爱或真实性爱。这对我来说是，在我听得够多之后，他们所说的真实性爱，指的是电话性爱。
Oh, really?
噢，真的吗？
Yeah, so it became, instead of a two-tier system, it's a three-tier system. And you have real sex, ultra-real sex, and cybersex.
对，所以它不再是一个两级系统，而是一个三级系统。你有真实性爱、超真实性爱和网络性爱。
Wait, ultra-real sex, you said?
等等，超真实性爱，你说？
That would mean what I call a slow-time interface, which means actual physical contact.
那意味着我所谓的慢时间接口，也就是实际的身体接触。
God, do people still do that?
天哪，人们还在做那个？
Yes.
是的。
Earl Jackson says that he meets more and more people who've hooked up what amounts to video cameras on their computers. With a technology called CU-SeeMe, they can look at the person they're interacting with over the net.
厄尔·杰克逊说，他遇到越来越多的人，他们把相当于视频摄像机的东西接到了他们的电脑上。通过一种叫CU-SeeMe的技术，他们可以在网上看到他们互动的对象。
I know people that actually leave physical dates to go home and have sex over the net with the quick cam.
我知道有些人甚至离开现实约会回家去，通过摄像头在网上做爱。
Come--
来——
It's true. There's an entire culture that's entirely video transmission sexuality now.
这是真的。现在有一种完整的文化，完全是视频传输性爱。
Talk a little more about that. You actually know somebody who actually left an actual date--
多谈谈那个。你真的认识某个离开真实约会的人——
Yeah, me, in fact. Yes.
对，实际上就是我。是的。
Oh, they left you?
哦，他们离开了你？
Yeah, they left me. But he said that that is what he does lately. And I understood that, because a lot of men are afraid of sexual contact because of AIDS. So the perfect thing to eroticize is distance.
对，他们离开了。但他确实说那是他最近在做的事情。我理解，因为由于艾滋病，很多男人害怕身体接触。所以最完美的性欲化对象就是距离。
And so he says to you-- at what point in the evening did he say, "I'm going to go home now?"
所以他对你说——在晚上的什么时候他会说，“我现在要回家了？”
Pretty soon. He said that he really needed to do the CU-SeeMe stuff.
很快。他说他真的需要做CU-SeeMe那些事了。
Back in December of 1993, Earl Jackson met a guy over the net in one of these gay chat rooms. The guy's name was Ken, lived nearby. But he had a boyfriend. So the two never met in person. But almost every day for a year, they got online together and created these elaborate fantasies together online, using that kind of software where you can see what the other person types as they type it, and they can see what you type as you type it.
回到1993年12月，厄尔·杰克逊在这些同性恋聊天室中的一个里通过网络认识了一个家伙。那个家伙叫肯，住在附近。但他有一个男朋友。所以两人从未亲自见面。但在一年里几乎每天，他们都在网上聚在一起，用那种你可以看到对方在打字时打出什么、他们也能看到你在打字时打出什么的软件，一起创造这些精心制作的幻想。
We would have a fantasy about, what if he came to my classroom and then I took him back into my office? But it was really sort of a game. But these narratives became so intense that we would set times of the day, or he would just check in. And he said, "Do you have time for a story now?" And he would start it. And then I'd continue it. And we have all of these stories.
我们会有一个幻想，比如如果他来到我的教室，然后我带他回我的办公室会怎样？但这确实是一种游戏。但这些叙述变得如此激烈，以至于我们会设定一天中的时间，或者他只是会查看一下。他说，“你现在有时间听个故事吗？”然后他会开始讲。然后我继续讲。我们有所有这些故事。
But as we kept doing this, then a little part of his life would come in. And then there would be a story that we take us somewhere else. And then I'd know a little bit more. And soon, the sex part was really an excuse to tell the other stories. And sometimes, he would be telling this story about his childhood in Missouri. And then it would remind him of a social fantasy. And then he'd put me in it. And you couldn't plan to do these things. We became sort of like jazz pianists or something. We'd have these riffs together.
但随着我们一直这样做，他生活中的一小部分就会进来。然后会有一个故事把我们带到别的地方去。然后我会知道更多。很快，性爱部分真的成了讲其他故事的借口。有时，他会讲这个关于他在密苏里州童年的故事。然后它会提醒他一个社交幻想。然后他会把我放进去。你无法计划做这些事情。我们变得就像爵士钢琴家什么的。我们一起会有这些即兴表演。
Then one day, he was asking me if I had time to talk to him. And I was just leaving. But I could tell that even the way he was typing was different.
然后有一天，他问我是否有时间和他说话。我正要离开。但我能感觉到即使是他打字的方式也不同了。
You could tell even the way he was typing was different?
你能感觉到即使是他打字的方式也不同了？
Yes. Yes.
是的。是的。
What do you mean?
这是什么意思？
People have different habits in their speed or the way he would respond or if he didn't put a smiley face after a certain number words. I just knew there was something really wrong with the way he asked me if I had time. And he said, "Bad news, son." And I think I knew instantly what that was. He had tested positive. And he didn't know how to break it to me. And our messages to each other then became a lot more about that and about what happened to him as a child and other things that were fairly tragic and amazing that he was telling anybody, because he was really one of the strong, silent types.
人们在打字习惯、速度，或者他回复的方式，或者他在某些字数后是否放一个笑脸，都有所不同。我只是知道他问我是否有时间的方式真的有问题。他说，“坏消息，孩子。”我想我立刻就知道那是什么了。他检测呈阳性了。他不知道怎么对我开口。我们之间的消息后来变得更多是关于那个，以及关于他小时候发生的事情，还有其他一些相当悲剧的事情，很惊人他会告诉任何人，因为他真的是那种坚强、沉默寡言的类型。
Then-- this is when I should have gotten more nervous-- he started saying that he didn't want any of his porn tapes anymore, because he associated porn with him being positive. So he wanted to mail them to me. And he mailed me a box of them. I didn't really want them, but he wanted to do this for me. So there was suddenly a box of porn tapes in my house. And then the following week, there was one, too.
然后——这就是我应该变得更紧张的时候——他开始说他不再想要任何他的色情录像带了，因为他把色情与他呈阳性联系在一起。所以他想把它们寄给我。他寄给我一箱。我真的不想要它们，但他想为我这样做。所以我的屋子里突然出现了一箱色情录像带。然后接下来的一周，还有一盘。
And just before I got back to San Francisco, I got a message from him, hoping that I was well and hoping I got the tapes. And he said that I'd get another message very soon. Now, he was writing to me almost entirely in capital letters, which scared me. And I didn't know why. But here's the last one. "I have it all boxed up now. I will give it to my friend. He will mail it for me like he did before. And it will arrive either Thursday or Friday via two-day express. I have a letter coming to you to help explain a few things. Thank you for being a friend when I really needed it. Kenneth."
就在我回到旧金山之前，我收到他的消息，希望我好，希望我收到了磁带。他说我很快会再收到一条消息。现在，他几乎完全用大写字母给我写信，这吓坏了我。我不知道为什么。这是最后一条。“我现在把一切都装进箱子了。我会交给我的朋友。他会像上次那样帮我寄。它会在周四或周五通过两天快递到达。我给你留了一封信来帮助解释一些事情。谢谢你是一个我真正需要时的朋友。肯尼斯。”
And then, three days, nothing. And then there's just one line. "A package should arrive today, 1/19/95. Email me. Cruiser3. Bye. Love, Ken. And then on the 25th, there was one that looked like it was from Ken. It was his screen name. But then, when I opened it up, it said, "This is a hard note for me to write. Ken left a note to ask me to let you know. Ken took his own life on Friday, January 20. He was cremated yesterday, and his ashes will be dropped into the ocean off San Francisco today. Ken's mental attitude over the last four to six weeks is very hard to describe. He was a basket case, to say the least. I will keep his account open for the next day if you have any questions or response, and I will try to answer them for you. Ken's friend, Dave."
然后，三天，什么都没有。然后只有一行。“包裹今天应该到达，1/19/95。给我发邮件。Cruiser3。再见。爱你的，肯。然后在25号，有一条看起来像是肯发的。那是他的网名。但当我打开它时，上面写着：“这是一条很难写的字条。肯留下了字条让我转告你。肯在1月20日星期五结束了自己的生命。他昨天被火化了，他的骨灰今天会被撒入旧金山外的海洋中。肯在过去四到六周的精神状态非常难描述。他彻底崩溃了，至少可以这么说。如果你有任何问题或回复，我会在接下来的一天里保持他的账户开启，我会尽量为你解答。肯的朋友，戴夫。”
Did he send you a final note in the last package he sent you?
他在寄给你的最后一个包裹里给你留了一张最终的字条吗？
Yeah. It was the only time I ever saw his handwriting. And that said similar things to this. it was just, "Thank you for being a friend when I needed it. And I will always love you."
对。那是我唯一一次看到他的字迹。上面写着类似于这样的东西。那只是，“谢谢你是我需要时的朋友。我会永远爱你。”
It must have been so strange to see a physical manifestation of him after the email.
在电子邮件之后看到他的物理表现一定很奇怪。
It was. And what was really odd was that, when he first sent the first box of tapes, he told me which tape had a scene where the two people are the ones that he imagined us to be. Now, that doesn't mean that he looked like either one of them. But he knew the fantasy scenario that would resonate with us. So even at that point, our fantasies were constantly mediated by some other technology. And-- which is probably hard for you to imagine-- but none of this cold. There was something so tender about this that I was very moved by this experience.
是的。真正古怪的是，当他寄第一箱磁带时，他告诉我哪一盘磁带有一个场景，其中两个人就是他想象中我们的样子。那并不意味着他看起来像他们中的任何一个。但他知道会引起我们共鸣的幻想场景。所以即使在那一点上，我们的幻想也被某种其他技术不断中介。而且——这对你来说可能很难想象——但这并不是冷的。这里面有一些如此温柔的东西，以至于我被这种经历深深打动。
After he died, did you go through a period of mourning for him?
他去世后，你经历过一段为他哀悼的时期吗？
Yes, I did. Yes.
是的，我经历过。是的。
What a strange thing to be mourning somebody who you never actually saw.
为从未亲自见过的人哀悼是一件多么奇怪的事情。
Yeah, although it's real. When people say, oh, the computers are making us all isolated and it's such a cold world, I've had emotional experiences and long-term friendships that would have never been possible otherwise.
是的，尽管它是真实的。当人们说，噢，电脑让我们变得孤立，世界是如此寒冷，我经历过情绪上的经历和长期的友谊，如果没有这东西，那是不可能的。
It's funny, because it's almost like the whole thing, it could be a con, an elaborate con.
这很有趣，因为它几乎就像整件事，它可能是一个骗局，一个精心策划的骗局。
But he would be such a creep that-- I thought of that, actually, because it seemed almost like a melodrama from a long time ago. It was really tawdry. And if I wrote a short story, I wouldn't end it this way, because it was too hokey.
但他会是个卑鄙小人——我确实想过，因为这看起来几乎就像很久以前的通俗剧。它真的很俗气。如果我写短篇小说，我不会以这种方式结束，因为它太老套了。
After he died, you know how after somebody you were close to is gone, how when you go back to the places where you used to go with them, you'll think of them inevitably and miss them. After he was gone, when you would get back on your computer, would you sense his loss?
他去世后，你知道在你亲近的人离开后，当你回到你过去常和他们去的地方时，你会不可避免地想起他们并思念他们。他走了之后，当你回到电脑前，你会感觉到他的失落吗？
Yes. Yeah, he really felt gone. He really felt gone. When I saw somebody else using his screen name, to get a stranger with his screen name, that was really, really chilling.
是的。是的，他真的感觉走了。他真的感觉走了。当我看到其他人使用他的网名，用他的网名得到一个陌生人，那真的是非常、非常令人不寒而栗。
Earl Jackson in Santa Cruz.
圣克鲁斯的厄尔·杰克逊。
Well, our program was produced today by Paul Tough, Dolores Wilber, Julie Snyder, and myself, with David Hauptschein, Alix Spiegel, and Nancy Updike. Contributing editors, Jack Hitt, Margy Rochlin, and consigliere Sarah Vowell. Production help from Laura Doggett and Sini Davenport. Today's program is a co-production with Chicago's Museum of Contemporary Art, Peter Taub, curator.
嗯，我们今天的节目由保罗·托夫、多洛雷斯·威尔伯、朱莉·斯奈德和我自己制作，大卫·豪普沙因、阿利克斯·斯皮格尔和南希·厄普代克参与。特约编辑，杰克·希特、玛吉·罗克林和顾问莎拉·沃威尔。劳拉·多格特和西尼·达文波特提供了制作帮助。今天的节目是与芝加哥当代艺术博物馆、策展人彼得·陶布的联合制作。
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
[鸣谢]
If you want to buy a cassette of our program, call us at WBEZ here in Chicago, 312-832-3380. Again, 312-832-3380. Our email address, [email protected] . You know, if you want to listen to any episode of our program for free over the internet, you can do it at our website, www.thislife.org. Thanks to KCRW for posting the sound files and to Elizabeth Wasserman, who designed and runs the site. This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International.
如果你想购买我们节目的磁带，拨打我们在芝加哥的WBEZ电话，312-832-3380。再说一遍，312-832-3380。我们的电子邮件地址，[email protected]。你知道，如果你想在网上免费收听我们节目的任何一集，你可以在我们的网站www.thislife.org上收听。感谢KCRW发布声音文件，以及设计并运营该网站的伊丽莎白·瓦瑟曼。《美国生活》由国际公共广播电台发行。
[FUNDING CREDITS]
[资助鸣谢]
WBEZ management oversight by Torey Malatia, who insists that he doesn't even know what Office 97 is, no matter what anybody says.
WBEZ管理监督由托里·马拉蒂亚负责，他坚持说他甚至不知道《Office 97》是什么，无论别人怎么说。
He actually was going to set me up with a copy of Office 97.
他其实打算送我一份《Office 97》的拷贝。
I'm Ira Glass, back next week with more stories of this American life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯，下周带着更多美国生活的故事回来。
PRI, Public Radio International.
PRI，国际公共广播电台。